- I'm very hungry.
(laughs)
I saved myself for this.
(upbeat music)
Today, we're gonna try...
- [Together] Kit-Kat Cookie Dough!
- I'm really picky about chocolates,
I don't like any, just
like normal chocolate.
- Oh, you gotta have shit in them.
- Kit-Kat and cookie
dough, I mean I don't know
how that's gonna taste but I'm excited.
- ...having a crappy day, and you're like,
"I just really want some
chocolate, to just amp me up."
- I over-saturate myself with chocolate.
- Like you over chocolate.
- I'm ready to try this
Kit-Kat Cookie Dough.
- Let's do it.
Oh I caught it!
- Yeah!
- Gimme a break.
- Cheers.
- I really don't think
this can go that wrong.
- It may also be good
if it's cookie dough.
- Looks like a sports bar.
- It does.
Get in the gym, get chunky!
♫ Gimme a piece of that Kit-Kat
♫ Is it chunky, is it fresh
- Oh, you can break off a
piece and share with your pals.
- I don't understand what I'm eating.
- I mean, I keep biting it,
so clearly it tastes good.
- I taste the extra
sugar, that's for sure.
- If you want a full on
dessert, this is better
than a regular Kit-Kat.
- This is like what you've
given up a little bit on life,
like you're like, "Girl, fuck that diet."
- Or flipping, your boyfriend
just broke up with you,
after you found out he cheated on you.
I'll eat the whole shit, gimme two!
- If I want cookie dough, I
would just eat cookie dough.
- They're just trying to
bring flavors together--
- I know.
- (mumbles and laughs)
- It's great, it's a
great dessert, I like it,
thumbs up!
- Maybe if there was more
cookie dough I would taste it.
- I feel like you expect
too much from candy bars.
- Maybe I do.